we've long heard how kovin 19 is hit
communities of color especially hard and
that includes Native Americans but
helpful
one tribe is coming from an unlikely
place far across the Atlantic one nation
is remembering a long ago act of
kindness and is enthusiastically
repaying the debt in Ireland there's a
special bond with Native Americans that
has stood the test of time
it all happened a hundred and
seventy-three years ago during the
potato famine a million mostly poor
Irish men and women starved to death
when a fungus destroyed the potato crop
the Choctaw tribe in Oklahoma came to
their aid the tribe understood hardship
many had died when 60,000 people were
driven off their ancestral lands and
what's known as the Trail of Tears they
decided to reach in their pockets and
you send that money over to the people
in 1847 Gary battens ancestors came up
with a hundred and seventy dollars
today's money probably would be a little
bit more than $5,000 but they said it
was more than just the giving it was the
giving of hope it was the giving that
somebody cared for you in those
desperate times why do you think the
Choctaw were so motivated to give when
here in America they were dealt an awful
blow themselves what the short answer is
empathy in Cork Ireland sculptor Alex
Pentek created kindred spirits to
commemorate the treasured gift
Gary batten now the Choctaw chief was
invited to the unveiling in 2017 and
still marvels at how the Irish people
appreciate something that happened so
long ago it's taught in their history
books every year I received postcards
from their students of their thinking
the Choctaw Nation for what they did
back during the potato famine and what's
really fascinating lots of people gave
me and when he came from Queen Victoria
and money came from Carcosa well the
real gift of the Irish remembered is the
gift of the Choctaw professor Patrick
one has made writing about the Irish
Native American relationship his life's
work then fast forward to corona virus
pandemic this year when the Navajo
Reservation was severely impacted there
Ethel branch sought help so this whole
thing was your idea I knew people would
be hit hard for various reasons either
you know living on a fixed income with
not adequate funding you know a third of
the nation has no running water
another third has no electricity so I
went ahead and started the GoFundMe in
Ireland Patrick Kerwin heard about the
appeal what moved you to donate I think
for most Irish people I think it's this
idea of finding commonality all of the
messages have been about this idea of
paying it forward of a sense of
remembrance and countless Irish men and
women saw this as a chance to pay back
for something they never forgot when I
started the fund
I put the dollars and I just thought
this is wildly optimistic I don't think
we're gonna make more than a thousand
dollars and now to be approaching five
million dollars is just amazing in a
little more than two months a team from
the Navajo and then the Hopi nations in
Utah Arizona and New Mexico organized to
distribute food and other essentials and
they are thanking the Irish so here we
are this 2020 we're in the middle of
this pandemic and lo and behold Ireland
comes calling to the Navajo Nation you
cannot teach things like that I mean
that's that's the things that surpassed
time we will stick together as human
beings
Ethel branch's goal to get two weeks of
groceries to some two hundred thousand
people is still hard to achieve but made
easier thanks to an enduring friendship
we're gonna be paying this back in the
future as well you know our children our
grandchildren
you know who knows how many generations
down the line it's really beautiful and
we definitely want to keep this going
and we're gonna tell this story to our
children well over five million dollars
as we speak it's an amazing tribute to
something that happened long ago
happening right now paying it forward
and fantastic love the story Michelle
great job and I love that it's more than
the giving it's the giving of hope